President Trump is in Vietnam right now
as part of his 12 day trip to Asia
there's been quite a bit of armchair
criticism of the president's actions in
China from pundits comedians and
politicians but how does that compare to
what he actually said today let's watch
Trump almost gone on his knees pulled
out a ring and proposed to the Chinese
premier spoke openly and directly with
President Xi about China's unfair trade
practices it'd be more accurate to say
Trump has spent his visit to China with
nose in but we can no longer tolerate
these chronic trade abuses and we will
not tolerate them it's one thing to not
blame them it's another thing to praise
them for ripping America off I expressed
our strong desire to work with China to
achieve a trading relationship that is
conducted on a truly fair and equal
basis you can almost hear the leadership
of the Chinese government laughing from
China to America the current trade
imbalance is not acceptable we are not
going to let the United States be taken
advantage of anymore I am always going
to put America first yeah it sounds like
he's really kissing up his Chinese there
and joining us now for reaction is
Lieutenant Colonel Tony Shaffer he's a
former Intel operative and vice
president of the London Center for
Policy Research I knew when he was there
was she with all the pageantry he was
doing the Trump strategy and tell us
tell us about what your impression was
about how he handled himself there and
all of the armchair critics well look I
like his snark when he said look he took
advantage of us you better get over and
move on I think it was a clear warning
and everybody completely here
misinterpreted that dear thing Laura
they showed him a great deal of
deference I mean he's the first leader
that's been to the Forbidden City that's
that's just not done and yet this is
completely missed by the mainstream
media it's all about snark the other
thing that he said he said very clearly
now I don't know this for a fact but I
have a feeling that one of the things
that he was probably suggested a threat
is their most favored nation trade
status that's huge I mean if you start
threatening how they were able to get
money from us and he's saying we need to
balance things that is in their face but
in a polite way so I would argue he's
been hard to the point of where now he
has to open up the door and say it's
time to talk an American president list
not my to my knowledge of my lifetime
has has not ever gone to China and
looked the Chinese leader in the eye and
said we know we're on to you we know
what you're doing and I don't mean I
work for President Reagan
I mean wait it obviously China was
remember the WTO back then but in
Clinton Bush did happen right didn't
happen so I think that was actually so
refreshing and he kind of said oh you
know I don't blame you he goes over to
Vietnam you don't think the Chinese were
watching him right when he lands we at
Nam and it was happened at 3:30 in the
morning that's the other point is gonna
make you know the Reagan folks I think
used to prepare but McFarland's a friend
of mine they used to always spend
President Reagan up ought to focus on
the man play the man and I think that's
what President Trump was doing here he's
playing the Chinese leadership he's got
to play them he can't play the issues so
the other thing is now he goes to
Vietnam and says oh by the way you know
we want to have a partnership with you
the other thing he's got in his pocket
right now is the fact that Vietnam has a
great economy the South Koreans have a
great economy the Japanese have a great
economy we really don't need the trade
with the Chinese to the level we do he
wants to do one on one by last side
agreements get out of these mega deals
where we always get the short end of the
stick and that's and that's him to me
that's doing trade the smart way this is
fulfilling his election promise that by
doing this walking away from TTP
bringing over the Bernie folks I know a
lot of Bernie folks voted for President
Trump because of it because that was
unfair and now I think he's trying to
bring back the the potential for trade
which will allow for American
manufacturing to get off its butt and
start doing more again so I see this as
a direct link to what he did a year ago
to be elected to start fulfilling these
problems the same time he did announce a
bunch of deals 250 billion dollars in
deals with joint ventures which is not I
mean it's it sounds big but the big
thing is trade but I think so I think
we'd have enough of the comedian's
making doing put foreign policy analysis
thank you so much